arrivant devant ce centre de vaccination
de bombay ces personnes trouvent porte
close
je suis venu ici pour recevoir la
première dose du vaccin mais ils ont
affiché un avis indiquant qu'il n'ya
plus de stocks et que la vaccination est
suspendu jusqu'au 12 mai on nous a dit
qu'il n'y avait plus de stock
ils ont mis une affiche à l'extérieur
indiquant qu'il n'y a pas de vaccin
disponibles ce samedi la vaccination
doit s'ouvrir à tous les adultes de plus
de 18 ans 600 millions de personnes sont
concernées
et pourtant dans sept autres centres de
vaccination même problème de pénurie
faute de stocks
l'activité ici aussi doit cesser pour
trois jours bombay n'est pas la seule
ville à faire face à ce problème depuis
au moins trois semaines dix états tirent
la sonnette d'alarmé comme celui de
l'orissa qui a déclaré avoir été
contraint de fermer 700 établissements
de vaccination une cause principale
explique ces pénuries
le manque de matières premières qui
servent à produire les sérums et des
usines inadapté
le ministre des affaires étrangères
tente de rassurer vous auriez vu que le
président américain joe biden s'est
entretenu avec le premier ministre
il a offert une aide considérable vous
auriez vu les détails de cette aide
aussi des états unis et bien sûr cette
aide est également allé dans les
domaines comme les matières premières
pour l'industrie des vaccins ce samedi
l'un doit recevoir à premier lot de
spoutnik v une goutte d'eau dans un pays
où l'épidémie est hors de contrôle et où
la campagne de vaccination est déjà en
retard
seuls 11 % de la population a reçu au
mans une injection